rien propos solennel et qui nous
rappelle ceci 37 ans déjà le temps
s'éloigne le souvenir reste très fort il
aura en effet 37 ans demain qu'au micro
de la BBC le général de Gaulle lançait
l'appel historique du 18 juin 40 pour
demander aux Français de ne pas accepter
l'armistice et de continuer la lutte
pour la liberté l'appel avait été rédigé
dans un immeuble de Londres au CAT
Carlton Garden et tapé sur cette machine
à écrire qui est l'une des pièces
historiques de institut Charles de
Gaulle à Paris et demain des
personnalités françaises de la
résistance se retrouveront dans le
studio reconstitué de la BBC avec le
vrai micro où a été lancé l'appel
n'oublions pas qu'aux yeux de ces chefs
militaires et du gouvernement de
l'époque le soldat Charles de Gaulle
devenait un dissident mais il avait le
sentiment de parler déjà au nom de la
France de Gaulle était presque seul ce
jour-là sans moyens sans armée et
pourtant vous connaissez la suite
Christian de
laacroix écrit en quelques heures
l'appel lancé par une voix venue de
Londres allait concrétiser la
résistance l'intérêt supérieur de la
patrie commande à tous les Français
libres de continuer le combat là où ils
seront et comme ils
pourront moi général de Gaulle
j'entreprends ici en Angleterre cette
tâche nationale j'invite tous les
Français qui veulent rester libres à
m'écouter et à me suivre et bien cet
appel était la suite des événements qui
s'étaient poursuivi pendant les jours
précédents car il avait fait tous ses
efforts comme sous-secrétaire d'État à
la Défense pour entraîner le
gouvernement Paul Renault à poursuivre
la guerre en Afrique du Nord ou dans ou
quelque part dans l'empire vous avez été
le grand témoin de la conception et de
l'élaboration de cet appel est-ce que ça
a été véritablement un acte solitaire ça
a été vraiment l'acte solitaire si
personne ne prend l'initiative et bien
de Gaul l'apprendra seul pour que la
France reste dans la guerre c'est ça en
clair la signification du de l'appel du
18 juin vous l'avez accompagné au studio
de la BBC je l'ai accompagné à la BBC
oui est-ce qu'il a eu l'impression à ce
moment-là d'avoir accompli un acte
historique et qui devait changer le
destin de la
France pour lui certainement c'était un
un grand pas et un acte de très grande
importance mais encore une fois il ne
pouvait pas même s'il le pressentait
dire ce jour-là toute la France va me
suivre car son appel aurait pu sombrer
dans l'indifférence si ça n'avait pas
été de Gaulle c'est de Go au fond qui
était l'homme du destin